i
[Música]
ah
si no ocupa de nuevo los puestos de cola
en la clasificación global de libertad
de prensa debido a la gran censura a la
que somete a sus medios de comunicación
el trabajo de los corresponsales
extranjeros aquí además cada vez es más
arduo los episodios violentos son muy
escasos pero la policía sí que puede
entorpecer su labor arruinarte un día de
trabajo o acosar a tu asistente y
entrevistados que son los eslabones más
débiles además existe la amenaza de que
las autoridades nos renueven tu carnet
de prensa lo que en la práctica equivale
a la expulsión del país muchos
periodistas de países anglosajones que
no guardan una buena relación con china
han tenido que irse en los últimos meses
debido a eso oa las grandes presiones
recibidas australia por ejemplo carece
de periodistas aquí por primera vez en
décadas mucho más grave y por desgracia
más ignorada es la situación de nuestros
colegas chinos que carecen de embajadas
que les protejan y están mucho más
expuestos a los abusos policiales
[Música]
no es nuevo que irán haga parte de ese
grupo de países que más persiguen y
reprimen a los periodistas pero este año
de la pandemia fue especialmente
particular por el poco acceso que
tuvieron los comunicadores a conocer lo
que estaba sucediendo en el país como
muchos otros países no tuvieron acceso a
las cementerios oa los hospitales pero
especialmente a las cifras verdaderas
que siempre se dijo que eran muchísimo
más altas que las que decía el gobierno
esto llevó a muchos periodistas a
expresar sus dudas en las redes sociales
y hacer sus comentarios lo que llevó a
la justicia a perseguirlos muchos fueron
llamados a la corte donde se les abrió
un proceso judicial actualmente hay 15
periodistas en la cárcel pero muchos de
ellos más muchos más tienen problemas
con la justicia pero el caso que más
conmocionó a la opinión pública fue la
ejecución de rudolf assam un periodista
opositor al cual se le acusó y se le
condenó de ser espía y más tarde murió
[Música]
egipto sin duda uno de los peores países
para ejercer el periodismo
consistentemente reporteros sin
fronteras lo pone entre los peores del
mundo y el comité para la protección de
periodistas lo sitúa entre los tres
peores solamente por detrás de china y
de turquía pero además desde que empezó
la pandemia las cosas no han hecho sino
empeorar muchos periodistas han sido
encarcelados por publicar noticias
relacionadas con el coronavirus que no
estaban de acuerdo con la línea oficial
el gobierno prohíbe directamente que se
publique ningún dato que no sea el que
da el ministerio de salud pero además el
año pasado pudimos ver claramente que no
solamente ser egipcio es el problema
porque los egipcios desde luego lo
tienen mucho peor que los periodistas
extranjeros que los corresponsales sino
que también los los egipcios están
siendo cada vez más superados con lo que
se publica fuera del país la periodista
ruth michaelson que trabajaba con el
diario británico guardián fue expulsada
del país poco después de publicar una
información en la
hablaba de cifras relacionadas con el
coronavirus y que no gustó nada al
gobierno egipcio que los periodistas se
nos envían cartas y pueden impulsándonos
y motivándonos de alguna manera aplicar
las versiones oficiales y ya no utiliza
ninguna fuente que se salga de lo
gubernamental
[Música]